la commission de l'économie du travail
étudie ces jours ci un projet de loi sur
l'allégement du fardeau administratif
pour les entreprises projet de loi qui
prévoit aussi des modifications au
zonage agricole québec veut permettre
aux petits producteurs d'avoir accès à
des terres en permettant le morcellement
des terres l'intention est saluée en
raison de la forte hausse des prix des
terres agricoles mais suscite des
inquiétudes quand même sur la protection
des terres agricoles avec nous en vrai
la montagne le ministre de l'agriculture
bonsoir monsieur la montagne bonsoir
monsieur fillion concrètement comment
pourrait-on où va-t-on même pouvoir
morcellement morceli terre en haïti ce
qu'on vient faire c'est que on s'entend
conte à la loi de la protection du
territoire agricole on a des
commissaires à la commission de
protection du territoire agricole qui
depuis 40 ans s'appelait qu'appliquer la
loi et dont le premier rôle c'est d'être
les protecteurs de notre zone agricole
ou alors ce qu'on vient faire dans la
loi c'est qu'on vient ajouter des
critères selon lesquels ils peuvent
étudier les différents projets qui sont
leur ruti leur sont présentés puis être
en mesure de rendre des décisions qui
vont être en synchronisme son voeu avec
les projets qui vont leur être
présentées et donc d'accepter finalement
qu'un territoire qui est
agricole puisse est détaché en morceaux
mais toujours pour des vocations à eric
agricole bien sûr l'idée c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a dans nos bassins
l'agriculture a changé depuis depuis 15
ans monsieur fillion qui ont aujourd'hui
dans nos écoles de 25 à 30% des
étudiants qui aspirent à pratiquer un
agriculture émergentes qui est pas
l'agriculture traditionnelle
et puis est important de fournir un
environnement à toute cette génération
montante note agriculteurs qui vont leur
permettre d'exprimer leur talent leur
passion mais au bénéfice de quoi bon un
bénéfice de la vitalité de notre dans la
zone agricole mais obéit au bénéfice de
vitalité nos territoires partout dans
les régions du québec cela dit l'union
des producteurs agricoles qui rien quand
même éloge réciter leur communiqué du 2
novembre que les terres morcelées
deviennent automatiquement une cible
idéale pour une maison manoir sur un
petit lopin de terre en campagne est ce
que votre projet de loi
empêche ça mais en réalité les
dispositions pour permettre
si en zone agricole sont encadrés de
façon très très clair et très sévère par
la loi de la protection du territoire
agricole et par les amendements qu'on
apporte on vient pas du tout du tout du
tout joué dans ces eaux là la seule
chose qu'on vient faire on vient donner
des op des outils additionnels ou
commissaires pour être en mesure
d'évaluer les projets à leur juste
valeur puis d'évaluer la viabilité de ce
projet leur contribution à la vitalité
de l'agriculture auquel cas échéant qui
vont pouvoir permettre de pratiquer
l'agriculture sur une superficie
couverte petit je comprends mais ce qui
est quand même une garantie qu une terre
agricole morcelé va demeurer à
s'emportant agricole est on est on est
pas on n'est pas dans le d'autoriser une
plus petite superficie pour une fonction
autres qu'agricoles c'est vraiment dans
un contexte agricole qui vise à
maintenir justement la vitalité de notre
territoire agricole alors quand lui paie
au 10 par exemple on regarde les micros
ferme par exemple élu période où on est
d'accord là avec la relève agricole etc
mais les micros ferme tendent à durer
moins longtemps et il est démontré que
plus les terres son petit - ils sont
utilisés par des fermes qu'est ce que
vous dites ça parce que j'ai encore là
c'est que le modèle agricole changé et
puis ce qui est important c'est que les
commissaires d'ailleurs l'an passé dans
le dernier budget on a alloué des fonds
additionnels à la cpt au cul pour lui
permettre de développer davantage
d'intelligence puits de connaissances
encore plus fine des modèles agricoles
pour être capable d'accompagner les
commissaires pour qui rendre des
décisions qui sont porteuses pour le
monde agricole alors ce qu'on cherche à
faire c'est chercher à s'arrimer avec
7,7 agriculture l'acquis et émergentes
mais encore là comme je vous dis le
premier rôle de la commission protecteur
et 3 du territoire agricole et des
commissaires c'est protéger le
territoire agricole est ce que dans
votre esprit l'époque des grandes fermes
est révolu
pas du tout pas du tout on n'est pas on
n'est pas dans une compétition de
modèles monsieur monsieur fillion on est
dans une situation où depuis 15 ans 20
ans il ya eu une accélération
d'évolution de takrit culture et
aujourd'hui on a un nombre important de
nos jeunes et moins jeunes agriculteurs
qui ont besoin d'un environnement qui va
leur permettre un d'exprimer leur talent
pas sûr mais aussi de gagner leur vie
honorablement alors l'objectif lorsqu'on
fait d'une façon très chirurgicale est
très posé je peux vous dire on vient
donner les outils et le cpt au cul
d'accompagner ces projets là ce sont les
projets porteurs qui vont être acceptée
sais pas comment vous expliquer les
inquiétudes de l'ue pea d'abord je vous
dirai en tout temps toute franchise je
sais quelque chose qu'on ne travaille
inclus père depuis deux ans avec lupe à
la fédé la fmq lui-même qu la cmm et
puis il peut arriver là que
naturellement on n'avait pas partager le
libellé du projet de loi parce que ça
doit être faite d'abord devant les
parlementaires alors sur le fond tout le
monde s'entend et puis s'il ya des
enjeux au niveau des libellés l'appui on
peut on peut on peut faire des
modifications pour rassurer ou s'assurer
le cas on rencontre bien l'esprit de ce
qu'on cherche à faire bien on vote en
commission parlementaire je vais être là
personnellement pour tout le bloc
agricole du projet de loi ppl 103 pour
travailler avec mes collègues pour
s'assurer de deux pays traversés soudain
projet de loi sur les allègements
réglementaire est ce que les
dispositions de la loi sur la protection
et greek somme qu'on est rendus loin
des allégements réglementaire le canton
est en train de repenser au zonage
agricole je voudrais dire un certain
nombre de de claude amendement qu'on
fait par ce projet de loi là puis je
voudrais maintenant au ministère les
cultures on a déposé puis
fait adopter quatre projets de loi
depuis le début c'est quelque chose que
je voulais m'assurer qu'on puisse faire
avant la fin de notre mandat et puis
l'agenda législatif de notre
gouvernement est très impressionnant
alors si le véhicule que j'ai pu trouver
le prêtre capable de venir apporter ces
modifications la au bénéfice de tout
notre monde est confronté dans le vide
alors le des wagons du projet de loi 103
merci monsieur la montagne noire suivre
ça de près avec beaucoup d'intérêt tant
plaisir mme sophie dire merci et bonne
soirée pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh
[Musique]